les possibles policiers les gendarmes se
sont eux qui me l'ont dit ce sont eux
qui n'en peuvent plus d'être dirigés
comme ils sont dirigés et les policiers
et les gendarmes à ce que vous dites les
policiers et les gendarmes ils vivent un
enfer
ils vivent un enfer au quotidien dans
leurs banlieues ils vivent un enfer au
quotidien pendant les manifs une action
qu'est ce que si je peux terminer c'est
une affaire grave
oui c'est très bien vivre un enfer et
ils sont attaqués de toutes parts et ils
sont courageux la quasi-totalité à part
quelques s'il ya une ou deux exceptions
comme ça moi je les soutiens les
policiers et les gendarmes toujours mais
en revanche dits sociaux les policiers
les gendarmes du commandement et quand
systématiquement voulait c'est
objectivement dans les manifestations
des gilet jaune rentrée des éléments
incontrôlés et que vous le savez
pertinemment
je dis oui qu'il y a eu des provocations
indigne de la part du pouvoir est
d'ailleurs monsieur castaner n'a jamais
porté plainte contre moi
suite à mes propos il a dit une
conférence de presse en disant qu'il
allait porter plainte en diffamation il
ne l'a pas fait et ce crime que ces
récipients
je maintiens mes propos car j'estime que
ce gouvernement a joué la prime avec la
france un seul jeu mais arrêtez avec vos
et la même chose mais arrêtez avec vos
espèce de truc mais vous êtes
complètement à l'ouest c'est
incompréhensible
la situation est d'une gravité social
d'une gravité sécuritaire pour que vous
êtes un peu de hauteur et transposent
mais je vais utilisation mêmes et de
leur faire part des avancées ont fait
exception le team in his de la noyade en
raison du nombre de décès et ils ont
joué avec le feu et à la fin qui en bave
qui en bavent les policiers les
gendarmes qui n'en peuvent plus des
manifestants qui ont subi des dommages
considérables eux et j'ai remarqué que
les hommes n'étaient pas les mêmes
quand c'était les petits trafiquants de
drogue dans nos cités ah si monsieur
castanet avec autant d'efficacité contre
les trafiquants de drogue que contre
lille gilet jaune
et bien je peux vous dire qu'ils
auraient moins de trafic de drogue en or
si on peut alors ça suffit mais là c'est
ça c'est l'un des maillots aux yeux
aussi les lieux différents je maintiens
et je vous savez quand je prends une
déclaration quand je fais déclaration je
me renseigne et je ne fais pas de
déclaration la main nicolas dupont